even though we all love money and food and
drink and all these other things the three
things that are consistent uh fulfillment
purpose and happiness you have believe my
mission is find a way to give more happiness to
People by allowing them to do certainly in their
career or Mission what they want to do where
they want when they want and do it how they
want to do it you have movement makers I've
got a community name kind of thinking about
breakthrough Builders going broad is the hardest
game the slowest game but the most sustainable
game so winning on YouTube for example it's the
hardest to get going because people don't know
who you are yet you got to build your brain and
a lot of people they quit along the way because
for that to become something that's financially
visible to support you most people quit because
they need to pay the bills that's why figuring out
like how can we make money while we're building
the brand is a lot more critical of some blue
lights flashing in my head so I can go away
and look at what's a blue light flashing just
good news yeah just good news it's not a red
light a red light would be this is bad news
blue light is good the blue light is okay
yeah I'm like I need a pen
and paper now Looney means
go perfect I don't want to miss any of this stuff
all right we got James in a house movement makers
came all the way to Toronto to do a one-on-one
so what's on your mind man how can I help
well there's a lot on my mind let's see but maybe
gave you some background I don't know if that
would help yeah yeah just to kind of talk about
the journey so for the last two and a half years
I've been coaching and Consulting with different
organizations and individuals and the first
business I built for myself trapped me okay so I
did the classic entrepreneur I've signed a bunch
of clients up not be able to build the systems or
the operational background to support them well
that became a strain I also didn't enjoy the work
so I was teaching people to build their businesses
from Zero to Hero if you like and I didn't
actually think about enough my ideal customer
and so I signed up customers who drained my
energy and so it was difficult for me to then
let go of the business because I built it to
a point where I would people would approach
me they would ask me to help them but I was trying
to back out and so by the end of 2021 I was really
back pedaling out of the business and thinking
about what am I going to do now because
well this is not a failure it's it's
made hundreds of thousands of dollars
this is not what I want to do it's not the dream
I had for myself when I thought about a fulfilling
and free life I wanted to do the things I loved
with the people I wanted when I wanted where I
wanted and it was none of those things it tend
to trap me in the house in my little home office
and I needed to find a way to kind of
break out of that so my solution was stop
don't fix this if you're not enjoying it seek Joy
close this down and so by April 2021 was I'd kind
of let go of my final client transitioned her into
another coach's environment so she could be taken
care of and then I went into okay what's next
September 22 I was like oh okay I know it's just
to take one step towards corporate life back to
the people where I know them the most I've got the
biggest Network and I can help them navigate their
careers rather than help people build businesses
even though I have that skill set now help people
with their career whatever it is they want to do
so I called it career remission growth and I just
help people grow transition transform to whatever
the next for them and and for most people even
though we all love money and food and drink and
all these other things the three things that are
consistent are fulfillment purpose and happiness
is that what I'll hear routinely over and over
with every client or Prospect I speak to is
they're the three things they want yeah so my
mission like you have believe my mission is to
find a way to give more happiness to People by
allowing them to do certainly in their career
or Mission what they want to do where they want
when they want and do it how they want to do it
so that's what I'm working on I love it no cool
harder to do in the corporate environment for sure
but I love it I think so many people incorporate
are not feeling fulfilled and happy and on Mission
and are struggling so they need you yeah it's been
my my early experience is the amount of pain and
denial going on but I was also that person that's
the younger version of me as a general manager of
a large software company I felt those emotions and
I also lived in denial and so it wasn't until I
invested in my own coaching I work with someone we
both know Brendan Bouchard he was kind of my coach
and spent a year in his you know company but
also working with his coaches and figuring out
personally what was it for me and how
could I develop myself professionally
and uh at the back at the back of that it was
like okay now I now I know how to take care of
me and I've got to make some bold moves and
so I had to make that bold move of leaving
the attractive salary and I a lot of my clients
we talk about it as the check and the chair you
get trapped by that salary and the dining room
you don't use and the double garage you don't
use and just all the niceties of of being on
a corporate ladder but the day by day grind
of operationally being in those environments most
people are not enjoying that and so my mission is
to help free them from that they can enjoy that in
that environment and and I became certainly a lot
more Carefree with coaching than when I was not
being coached so when I was not being coached it
was all about the external world but when I was
being coached it was all about me and so I need
to take care of what I can control and then
what can I influence that's going to make a
difference in my external world so I don't feel
grotty what's karate karate that's a that's a
British word for misery okay perfect I'm learning
something new great yeah cool well I mean how can
I help where are you at what can I give you some
feedback on so I launched an on-demand course in
November so Black Friday I ran a little promo for
that week to get a few clients in to see if people
would buy this in an on-demand environment and
so three people did and then one of those people
transferred to a one-to-one coaching environment
with me and so that was the end the beginnings of
okay I can replicate the successes of the first
business in this business on a one-to-one model
so let's test how many one-to-one clients
could I get and so January she signed up
and since that time I've added another 15
people who are all on a 90-day 12-week program
my challenge now is one of Time how do
I transition this to a one-to-many model
how do I balance the business so the way that it
doesn't do what the first business to me which is
constrained me yeah I'm now looking for solutions
to what's the transition path for me to go to one
to a one-to-many model do do my clients want
that in the format and then what what are the
things I need to build to make that successful so
operationally how do I need to do that but what
does the product need to look like I saw you I saw
you talk about Benjamin Hardy and Dan Sullivan and
I love Dan Sullivan and what Bob Sullivan what
they've done in their environment to create this
one-to-many environment I always think maybe
that's where I'll be where Dan is in his 70s
I'll be in my 70s having this Legacy of there's
all of this free content of how you do this
and on a one-to-many basis but there is this
ability to to be closely Mastermind groups so
I'd love to be able to figure that transition
out now from one to one for what I'm doing how
do I take it one to many how do I create
masterminds I'd love to do a live event
and pull everybody I've ever worked with
together maybe in Dallas or another city
and think about how do we just give them two days
of excellent value while we're there so they walk
away and they are in charge of their career and
their mission and they know for themselves and for
their families exactly where they're going awesome
so there's a couple ways to do it and and then
which one you pick is really a hard question which
one do you want to do because which one could work
all of them which one will work is the one that
you actually feel most aligned to and connected
with so option one is you just keep going as
you're going and you keep increasing your prices
which then you limit who you can work with it's
going to now become you know c-suite or up and
coming to people that afford your rates because
now you're going up that's inherently limited you
know whatever your upward cap is 20 clients at a
time 30 clients at a time but you're not doing 400
clients one-on-one at a time just not visible
there's an upper limit to that so you could
build a three four hundred thousand dollar a year
Consulting business as a solo entrepreneur with
um one or two kind of virtual people on your
team and it's highly profitable it can be highly
fulfilling it's not scaled you just described the
first business yeah and the way this is going yeah
that's where it will land yeah I already predicted
that's exactly the the size the shape and and how
it will operate that's a great starting point
because now you have money coming in so you're
not just I don't know where money is coming from
right so now you've got that so great and and for
some people that's actually enough for some people
once they hit three four hundred thousand dollars
a year their ambition shrinks like you know this
is actually pretty good life and so no judgment
you know that's if that's what you actually want
to create but you've already been there before you
know that's not what you want to create so that's
step one two is you find a way to if you want to
keep a small number of clients you find a way to
tack on to their success it's a little harder in
the corporate world in the entrepreneurial world
it's like you take a piece of the business so you
keep working with the 20 people 30 people but
you're going to own five percent of the company
and that's how you scale because as they grow
their businesses you own five percent of this
business and so you meeting with them once a
week every two weeks or whatever the Cadence
is going to be has much higher upside because you
have that Equity piece you could still take your
fees for coaching them yeah but it's fee plus
equity and the equity is the real upside okay
the corporate world's harder because there's no
business but does it tie to Performance percentage
of salary if they get an upgrade if they get a
raise do you get a piece of the raise kind of
thing like you're basically with them for longer
than a 90-day period you're picking horses to bet
on to say I love these people and I want to work
with them for the rest of my life and you share
on the upside all along the way right it might
alter how you change your programs it's not just
90 days in and out but for what you do they
still need you in a year and in two years yes
because now they have new challenges and new
life situations and a new bar so they move to
a new company and all of a sudden you know they
need all those things again even if you're just
reminded of the things that you already taught
them two years ago they they need that ongoing
reminder and they need the sounding board as well
so you could position it as 90 days in and out
or you could realize that hey this could also
be an ongoing thing for people if you're great
at what you do they should be coming back a
year later and say hey keep helping me whether
that's feasible to have a piece of their salary or
some kind of performance uh related thing that's
easier in the entrepreneurial world but that's
a another model to consider the third one is you
have coaches underneath you so James is the it's
a law firm model right James is a senior partner
and then you've got Associates underneath you
yes and you're the one charging 2 000 bucks
an hour and they're charging 500 bucks an hour or
whatever whatever the model looks like yeah right
to make that work you have to love mentoring
and training people right so it's less client
delivery and more mentoring your team so if
you love mentoring team more than you love
working with clients you still have your clients
your roster but it's really about bringing these
people up underneath you okay right the next model
is one-to-many which is what you know you brought
up at the start so whether it's a Dan Sullivan
model where you have in-person meetings and
zoom or something like mover makers where you're
creating a community around the course and going
back deeper on the training you're you're coming
up and doing your training and then you have you
know hundreds of thousand ten thousand however
many people in the room that you're you're who've
bought into your program that can facilitate
to then you know workshops and one-on-ones and
Live Events and bigger things within their there
there is a tremendous value in people getting to
know each other especially in the corporate world
and so there is a huge value in the masterminding
whether it's in person or even virtual on Zoom
even here we're doing a little mini Mastermind
you're you're up first so we're here talking
but the others are masterminding downstairs
you go join them after and you get to meet
other people who are kind of doing similar
things and there's the let's learn from Evan cool
but there's also good to connect with each other
same thing in mover makers it's the let's learn
from Evan for the first 40 minutes or whatever it
is and then it's breakout rooms to connect with
each other because a lot of great stuff happens
so if you love facilitating and love setting up
introductions and connections for people and it
doesn't have to all be about James then that's a
good model as well yeah right so movement makers
have found oh people love me but they love talking
to each other so let's let's facilitate that too
instead of just me talking for 85 minutes and
then the last one is massive scale where you're
you're looking at YouTube videos you're looking
at books it's a lot of micro transactions instead
of a few bigger transactions you have a topic
that's big enough to go like who doesn't have a
you know I guess all the entrepreneurs don't
have jobs but a lot of people have jobs a lot
of people have careers a lot of people are
struggling with purpose and happiness and
fulfillment all the things you talked about so
there's that upside possibility to hey I want to
build a Channel with a million subscribers and I
want to make money off of sponsorships and brand
deals and advertising revenue and book deals
and selling low ticket things to many people
so those are some options [Laughter] that
makes sense the only one in there that I
can say that's not the path I'm looking at is
the mentoring and training of a large group of
coaches okay I'm very comfortable to pick up two
or three assistant coaches who would then do that
that's their function so I think about you know I
talked about Brandon and my relationship with him
he has a Lady Lauren jono you may know Lauren
and Lauren has the team of coaches so a lot of
Brandon's work is actually with Lauren and Lauren
then disseminates and trains the organization so
I see that as a model that I could use that way
so all the rest of it yes and I would like to
kind of improvise on that and Tack on I'd also
want the ability to to speak on stage you know
it's how we met in in September 2019 I saw you on
stage and and that's what I'd like to do as well
as have that as another stream in addition to all
the other things you said so my question is now
from where I am in one to one coaching a group
of maybe 15 people which and then I just kind
of deploy Jeff Walker's methodology of you
can find 15 you'll find another 15. yeah and
I'm absolutely trusting that in the course of
this year I can find another 70 to 100 people
and I've set myself a mission statement of cell
200 coaching memberships to to organizations
before the end of 2024 and that I know I can
do that just by doing what I'm doing now but
what what if I could double that what if I could
triple that what's the quickest way to do that
that is going to allow me to live the way I want
to do yeah and what I've not shared with you is a
couple of personal missions the first one is my
son is autistic and so my primary focus in life
is is him his name's Rory he's seven years old
about to turn eight in June and so for him a lot
of my time is focused on him so when I was in the
corporate world I'd see him maybe 30 minutes a day
now I have somewhere between four or five hours
with him a day and that's a really big thing
for me on the personal side so that I can also
connect with my wife we both work at home she's
there she's working a full-time role for herself
and she's enjoying the process of what she does
and maybe she'll look at different things in
the future as well so I want to manage that
so time is of the essence for me because because
I'm very strict really on a six hour work day is
I do an hour of reading and planning around
movement makers and things that I do in the
morning reading momentum is kind of where I'm at
right now I'm writing my book while I'm reading
you kicking me about momentum and then I'm writing
my book alongside that and then I spend five hours
of coaching marketing selling the services which
includes you know write-ups of session notes and
delivering video back to the clients so that they
get an awesome experience because I want them to
come back because I actually I want them to take
the 90-day experience and then go straight into a
12-month agreement with me so they stay around
for longer and that they're just going to give
them greater results the challenge I have now is
where do I go next and the timing of that so for
this quarter I could be going another 15 to 20
memberships and then by the end of that quarter
I'd like to be thinking about the second half
of this year really having a different format
and is that go broad Mass scale with more
video and create low ticket items 7.27 items
or is that nope go to the one-to-many model which
kind of Dan Sullivan's model there of creating a
mastermind or break you know you have movement
makers I call it I got a community name kind of
thinking about breakthrough builders for careers
okay and yeah I hope someone doesn't steal that
you know you'll get the domain name yeah go get
the domain name that's right yeah and and so I I
love the idea of having a membership business yeah
like that that is Affordable monthly affordable
but then also having a mastermind group Which is
higher tier it's kind of vice president and above
is people are paying a decent amount of money
every year I mean not maybe thousands maybe tens
of thousands of dollars to be in that environment
to have access to the other c-suite members yeah
to build their Network that way so that's
that's really my question tens of thousands
if you're talking about yeah I think at 25k
is kind of the base there yes yeah for sure
you know it really just depends on your
patience level because going broad is this
is the hardest game the slowest game but the most
sustainable game so winning on YouTube for example
it's the it's the hardest to get going because
people don't know who you are yet you got to build
your brand you got to get a great message from the
camera get comfortable all that kind of stuff not
that you're not but it just takes time to build
the brand yeah and a lot of people they quit along
the way because for that to become something
that's financially feasible to support you
most people quit because they need to pay the
bills right so that's why figuring out like
how can we make money while we're building the
brand is a lot more critical so you can do it
that I'm just going to do coaching one-on-one
and keep my 15 people or 20 people whatever is
sustainable inside your four hours a day and then
you have two hours to do other stuff right build
the brand or you can go coaching group and then
build the brand what you know the more financial
resources you have the more you can invest in
team to do a lot of the stuff to help you the
more it's you trying to figure everything else out
everything's going to go slower especially when it
goes to YouTube world where it's I got to figure
out my thumbnail and the title and all the you
know the editing if that's you that's probably not
a great use of your time unless you're interested
and you're curious yeah you love learning right
right but even me we've got 52 people on the team
now right could I figure out how to do video yes
but like Danny's way better than me and I wouldn't
know what light to get and like the three camera
setup we've got and all this stuff right could I
figure it out is it interesting yes but I'm I'm
a naturally curious person but you can me you
we can apply our creativity to problems that
are much more aligned with our mission than
you fiddling around with a YouTube thumbnail as
your hour of of problem solving time yeah right
so in general I would say you start with your
one-on-ones then you go to your groups and then
you go abroad you can still start broad now
but it's not a major investment yet because
you have so much Financial opportunity in the
Second Step that then allows you to hire a team
to help you with the brand building and do
all the stuff that you don't like to do yeah
that's a logical way to do it you know if your
heart say no I want to just go with that first
like we can we can make it work right but if
you were to go you've got 15 people now 15 yeah
so and they're on a 90-day cycle some of them
are on 12 months because they're c-suite so
the c-suite people sign up longer so I have two
products yeah you know when we first spoke on the
Instagram live yeah you said just focus on that
core product so I did and I've been selling the
90 day yeah because I think it's an easy on-ramp
I'm not charging incredible amounts of money right
now so in my first business there were packages of
6K 12K 25k right now I started at 1500 to make it
very easy for people to work with me so those
that first lady I talked about she paid 1500.
but I'm already up to the 3K level but my
goal is to get it back to 506k for that 90-day
package and then for an annual package you'd be
looking maybe at 12 to 18K as an executive in a
one-to-one environment but I want what I'd like
to do is then migrate to groups so put people
into a either a six month or a 12-month membership
like movement makers where if they're if they're
having coaching and the group experience too then
obviously there's a higher fee but if they're
just in a membership then I can reduce that
dramatically and open it up to a bigger group
so you still have a lot of senior people turn
up into that call but it does have a lot of
Junior people too who currently not wouldn't
necessarily want to invest thousands of dollars
with me if they're not even a manager there
if they're an individual contributor in what
they do so they work in a product or service
business and they're just doing a function
they might not want to take any of their paycheck
and give me thousands of it my target is really
director and above I don't really I want to help
senior managers get to that director level but but
I want to make sure that the people in the group
everybody's had I call it a scene a bit of life
for sure so they've got plenty of experience
because I want that Mastermind to have the value
of exactly what you said when we turn up in a room
together I don't want anyone to feel out of their
depth I want people to be able to say just like
with this experience of walking here this morning
I meet three people and they're already giving
me tons of ideas in the first five minutes I want
that same experience for clients when they come to
a live Mastermind event or a community event where
it's it's the people around you that are going to
make the biggest difference for you and it's not
so much about people being out of their depth
it's the other way of the people who are above
don't want to be spending their time with
people who are like four levels below
yeah so they certainly for certainly for
the c-suite people I'm working with now
they wouldn't want to go below that blow director
that would be that's what I don't really want to
be talking to people who even with managing large
groups or managing managers yeah and it depends
on on the size like a c-suite yeah is nebulous
depending on how big a company we're talking
about right yeah so the media businesses they're
kind of 10 million dollar plus right oh yeah but
still so like c-suite of a 50 million different
to a c-suite of a large corporate compared to
a director of a five million company is a big
difference right so it's just something to pay
attention to like is there enough value for every
person coming and especially on the Mastermind
where they're helping each other out yeah I
think it's really just a Financial Choice for you
to figure out what that balance is of people
coming in and spending 90 days with you it
could be 90 days and then they join the thing it
could be 90 days plus the thing The Mastermind the
group there could be no 90 days and it's just the
group yep okay come in yeah um there's probably a
difference between the group that meets every
two weeks or whatever your Cadence is going to
be and then the Mastermind which is more valuable
probably by getting together in person and meeting
once a quarter right so if you had what Cadence
were you thinking about for the the one-to-many
for a mastermind environment well what a lot
of our live experiences yeah the live would be
virtual yeah virtual so I'll talk you through
I did the first business and I went too fast
listening to you is just kind of good to hear the
word patience because what I did was one-to-one
sold five projects five programs and then
immediately put everybody into a group so I went
to the group model so I could save my time and I
coached him on a Monday and a Friday every week
so which would probably too much touch Point
yeah so I would roll back from that and so I
think for a one-to-many group environment like
that I would still do once a one once a week
or once every two weeks as a maximum but for a
mastermind that was as more expensive I would
think once a quarter and the equivalent of that
in my first business was I did two and three day
live events that were virtual because it was all
happening during it so there was no opportunity
for me to get everybody together anyway even
though people would have loved that I think
we just spent time on a Thursday Friday Saturday
two two and a half day events the last day would
all be always be a half day and a kind of
integration day of let's take everything we've
learned and let's put it into an action plan and
actually take some actions before you leave today
and then we'd wrap up you know with a dance and a
song at lunchtime and and I love that but I'd love
to do that live because I've done that virtually
and so it's a it's a huge rush of energy up to
it and then there's kind of big drop off at the
back end for me for me I gotta learn you know that
after the event you're taking two or three days to
do nothing to yeah kind of physically recover and
our last one that we used to do those in-person
events here too just before covet and our on our
last one uh I somehow had a half hour break at the
end for I don't know why and I lay on that floor I
was dead right I need to whoa and I just I I crash
for half an hour before then going out for dinner
yeah it takes a lot you give a lot I mean I didn't
know you could do 20 000 steps in your bedroom you
know that was kind of the experience yeah I stood
up all day yeah bouncing up and down in different
breaks you know that business was high energy so
it kind of had that Tony Robbins we're gonna have
a song and a massage about it but but I didn't um
I didn't realize how much draining that was so I
don't want to go back to that and actually this
this target audience I don't think they want to be
jumping around in their houses and I don't think
they want to jump around too much it's much more
of a a mature audience the people are typically
late 30s and above is kind of the age bracket
and I've got clients up right now to 65 as the
oldest client I have so that's kind of the window
35 to 65. they've they've had a career already
they've done 15 to 20 years and they've been
successful they just want more of those things I
want the more success more meaning in their life
they thought they wanted to climb the ladder they
got to a certain point and now they're saying oh
was me being vice president or general manager
or CEO of a company really what I wanted because
now I'm here I'm not enjoying it yeah and
you have a course around others too yes I
have a 12-week curriculum that everybody follows
inside the so even if we're talking about somebody
who's comes to me for interview assistance and
connections into large corporates so they can
have conversations I still put them through the
curriculum so we'll talk about their circumstances
but then as an example we start with Clarity and
we talk about commitment and competence and skills
and intention all the things that you would
I'd expect to see in any any program so we'll
have those kind of conversations how often do they
need to revisits like module one is what clarity
for the on-demand course so there's two things
the undermine courses are kind of you can go as
four modules it's alignment which includes Clarity
okay alignment so how often do I need to revisit
alignment on my career every six months Maybe
cool and there's a four module on-demand program
and it's called alignment aim which is creating
a personal North Star something you're going to
go for yeah and then execute which is act what's
the difference between the four module on demand
and the that's four modules you can do it in
three hours and every six months you can keep
coming back because you pay for it once okay um I
actually think about longer term switching that to
a membership and you pay for that 275 bucks a year
let's say yeah and you just have access to it for
the rest of your life you know and I keep adding
content to it so it just gets bigger and better so
for 275 you get a ton of value and the 12 month
the 12 the 12 12 week is a 12-week curriculum
um so it Loosely follows the same four modules
there are 12 distinct sessions and that's your
coaching that's my one-to-one coaching
guided yeah so so here's what I'd suggest
you take your 12 week and you turn it into into
group content you do it over every two weeks
instead of every week so now it's a 24-week
program so it's going to come live with you
because there's a lot of implementation has to
happen yes so if you're teaching twice a week
they're not doing anything it's just too much to
unless one of these like super hardcore which some
people will be but most people will not no less
than five percent yeah so so you're losing most
people and so I would take that 12-week content
teach it every two weeks so it becomes 24 weeks
and then revisit it again so twice a year you
basically go through the content day too even
if it's the same content we're just revisiting it
because now we're back to alignment again because
you've grown over the past six months are you back
how is your alignment how is your Clarity how is
your whatever all this and I do that now in the
12 week There's a reset so week five and and then
week nine I'll reset weeks okay so we're resetting
on aspiration hey we just did four weeks of
coaching yeah you went away and took some actions
you had some conversations you met some VIPs do
we still have the same aspiration and the reason I
do that is because nobody does yeah they suddenly
realize oh working with you is allowing me to
level up I'm thinking about things differently
I've had these distinctions I'm having a hard
moments and epiphanies about I always wanted this
and for some reason I railroaded myself and I
just went in One Direction and now you're showing
me all the things I Ever Wanted are possible for
me we have the aspiration reset and where people
had said to me I want this paid position now
they say I do want the pay position but I do
want my book to be done I do want to create my
channel I do want to create my coaching business
on the side or I do want to leave corporate
life great but I didn't feel like that five
weeks ago because now you've shown me the path
now I know I can leave corporate life and do a
service based business whether I'd be a coach
consultant expert practitioner you've got the
model right I could work with you and you could
teach me how to do that yes that's exactly how
you could do this so design a one-year curriculum
that you're going to teach every two weeks right
and that might be the same thing four times or the
same thing three times or the same thing just same
thing twice twice whatever whatever like actually
gets results right and you go through a year of of
that and if they're buying an annual membership
with you whatever that costs and the focus of
coming to the sessions much like movie makers
is implementation so you tell them go watch this
video go watch this training here's the content
we're back to alignment again I know we did it six
months ago but now things have changed go read
through the alignment questions again and then
when they show up live you can do the exercising
you could do a quick recap but it's implementation
how did this land for you what problems are
you facing the biggest shift for me which I
think is creating the stickiness so I've got
people coming to the end of their 90 days now
and so far I've 100 hit rate so nobody's leaving
so I know it's working because it's got that stick
rate of done with you whereas in the first
business Monday Friday were the coaching
sessions but it was a do-it-yourself and so yes it
overwhelmed people and so only the hardcore people
got results with it but why people were able
to do is take all those skills and deploy them
in their paid positions so people got results at
work but not in the thing that they wanted to do
and that's why I made that adjacent step but
yeah you're absolutely right I think I think
um doing it with people matters so every week when
I meet my coach tomorrow when I have my coaching
sessions kind of back to back a little bit yeah a
little bit we'll be going through let's go through
your resume and look at all the the verbiage
and make sure this is the power verbiage we need
and then take a look at the opportunities you've
uncovered and then tie the things together so that
you're ready for when you walk out here today
you can put three conversations straight into
place with the partners you need who are going to
introduce you to the people who could then create
the roles for you because you know one of the one
of the big things I want people to understand is
the application model is fundamentally flawed
so it's going to be hard for you to get a job
if you're applying all the time I want you to
create the job you want and that means having
the conversation and building the relationship
first and we do that through the network so
that's that's been the real fun stuff and so what
they're seeing yeah because I'm the guy who is the
connector in the relator that they're seeing that
that's the way that they can well and as you get
to larger groups there's only so many people you
can bring up and do implementations with so if you
said okay today we're focusing on our resume and
here are the activities that you're supposed to
have watched before cool let's show up okay let's
work on our resume you guys watch the training who
needs help this is what we mean we do as a movie
makers we're meeting in two days yeah right so
he's like hey here was the train I'll be at the
airport Biz Dev show like who needs help what do
we got and I'll work with three or four people on
their thing but as you scale up the group if you
have a thousand people in there yes we can learn
from the three four people you've got in there but
then that's where the breakout rooms become really
helpful to have a smaller group where everybody
gets a chance to talk hopefully we're giving them
five six people in a room to then do the exercise
and share with each other and get some feedback
so that's how you end up scaling it it's like
you have the group but it's not teaching anymore
in the group you've already created the course go
watch the course we're focused on implementation
here yes right so you bring up people do some
hot seats go to breakout rooms so they can
share and that's been my core message in it I
don't know I don't know if that was something
that you I picked up from you along the way
but in my sales proposals and in my sales
conversation I say this is not a learning program
this is an Implement implementation program
it's going to be intense but you're going
to have more fun doing than you are planning for
planning yourself to death you know it's kind of
people just keep planning and not actually doing
anything like I was planning my book until I read
momentum and now I'm writing let's go there's
15 000 words in there this is great you know
that's an easy model it's just the the price point
isn't as high as the one-on-one so as you're going
through this phase of you've got all one-on-ones
which is paying more and and you know nice now to
move to if you move everybody over now we've like
dramatically cut how much we're making every month
so that's where the the however long your Runway
is to get people into the program if you moved
all 15 into your program maybe that's not enough
anymore financially so how many more people do
we have to fit in to make that happen yeah right
does it have to be 100 people 50 people 400 people
like at what point yeah I already got the mission
it's a thousand okay yeah the mission's a thousand
but to replace your income okay yeah how many
you've got 15 clients right now one-on-one some
are 12 months some are 90 days if you just moved
everybody into your group program you could do
that yeah but you're taking a huge hit financially
yeah which is not great right so what what is
the Delta there of like how much do we need to
make on the group side yeah to then cover your
like match words to do it the way I think about
it is I'd always maintain those people in the
executive track who the 12-month commitment
or or six months depending if I'm helping
them with their business I would maintain those
clients I actually really not always not always
right okay but I'd maintain them until that
group had hit the what do we want to call that
you know kind of minimum viable group size
that the income is then at the right level so
it can then I can focus on just putting more
members into the group and scale it that way
and how many of your 12 people or 15 people
are the CEOs versus the 3C Suite of the 15.
to 20 uh c-suite people three out of the 15 are
the on the 12 months and the other 12 are on the
12 week I have one C Suite on 12. I have three
people on six months okay everybody else is on 90
days okay the six months people are two business
Builders at c-suite and then the other 12 months
yeah so so uh I'm testing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah testing at the beginning what works yeah
yeah I know I now know I can sell 6 and 12. I
don't I could get rid of the 90 day completely
and you probably want to kill the six too like
having too many offers especially the beginning
no I I'm remembering it's just it's it's chaos
so you have your 12-month c-suite program for
now yeah which will evolve into a mastermind where
you're not you're not doing any one-on-ones unless
they're paying you an obscene amount of money
or you just love the person and you want to
but it's a it's a passion Choice more than
uh I need this to you know he already asked
me how does he stay on and I said you pay double
yeah great yeah and he said oh okay can we talk
about this again I said yeah the answer will
be triple yeah so it and that's the way I I've
already positioned that with him he's the Chief
Operating Officer of a 20 million dollar business
so I'm not worried about the affordability of it
because I know that he's gonna yeah his ultimate
goal is to build that business and exit and I
don't have any skin in that but he could walk
away with three percent of the sale let's say
it's a 5x multiplier he's walking away with a
pretty healthy you know five five million right
well maybe maybe you get skin in the game yeah
maybe that becomes part of the percentage yeah or
maybe not his percentage he's a c c o o c o o yeah
is it a public company no no the private company
and the the founder the CEO was the founder is
the majority shareholder so this is where there's
opportunity is that okay it's 20 million company
that's not huge but it's not it's not a startup
right that's down good so can you come in and help
not just him but help the whole company in some
way and the composition becomes one percent equity
in the business I don't have an invitation from
the CEO to do that so I'm working with the Chief
Operating Officer to get to the point where he can
say we need James in the business and so if we can
get James into the business then that's going to
make a difference to have you had the conversation
he hasn't had that conversation yet no but have
you had the conversation I've had the conversation
with him yes okay yeah but he hasn't talked to the
c c now because he's one one step at a time for
him because he's also I think eight months in row
so he's cool being patient with his conversations
about it and you have to love him and you have
to love the company because now if it's an equity
play you're getting married to somebody and so
that's right but that's how you can potentially
scale if you're not going after giant companies
you're going after 10 to 50 million dollar
businesses that are privately held there's Equity
pools on the table that could be a a play for you
but with my skill set I know that I can help those
businesses yeah not just be 20 million businesses
but be 40 and if they exit at 40. everybody's
winning and so that's that's the goal is to be
is to have on those kind of retained clients who
have a percentage I have a percentage in the game
yeah the ones so for those I'd love to be able to
do some of that work too but I I restricted that
to maybe you know sign one of those every couple
of months yeah it could be when they come I mean
you know when they have to yeah I mean Tony Tony
Robbins models it's a million dollars for coaching
plus a percentage of the company yeah right um
so you've got your you've got your group training
what we call it something builders breakthrough
breakthrough Builders you like that get the
domain name yeah breakthrough builders that is so
we're not selling our 90-day program anymore we're
not selling the 12 week we're not selling the
sixth week or six months we're selling the group
which is the course and the training every
two weeks live with you and then breakouts
for them to meet each other that's one offer
the other offer is a 12 months exactly CEO
executive track whatever that also will that will
evolve into a mastermind or an equity play yeah
we don't have to worry about that yet until you
get enough people in there to make it a depends
what type of business they are really yeah yeah
The Mastermind could be as long as there's a fit
with each other makes sense the equity that's much
more on you to say do I want to spend the next 10
years with these people or not helping to build
this business luckily in this business that's why
I feel really good about the people I'm meeting
great so it's very different the first business
not every I I just don't think I did the classic
good enough job of Ideal client Avatar that when
I went into that I just thought that I could
because I was cocky yeah I thought I could
service everyone and there are the reality is you
really can't and and so a lot of those people are
not people I would want to serve but this time
around it's very different I think it's because a
lot of those people are on my journey or or want
to be on my journey and so we have much more in
common our values are the similar there's
a lot more family orientation of the group
so there's there's a lot more at stake for them
to make sure that they Implement them because
if they don't Implement they just get stuck
in the relationship ends and so I feeling a
lot more accountability this time than I do the
first time around so I mean that's the starting
point and it's pretty if you already have the
course you're already doing the 12-week training
you just have to figure out what is whatever
you look like yeah right you could do that
over lunch right like that's not something that's
going to take months to figure out yeah I did the
12-week curriculum in about 10 minutes and you
can do it quick because you've already done it
right you're not brainstorming this from nowhere
you have the experience as a coach so that's it
can happen quickly and then you just start
selling it like you can talk to the first
12 people or whatever you've got to say
okay I'm after 90 days we're transitioning
to this and I mean new people coming in you can
transition to that and then just pick the dates
that you're going to be doing it and every two
weeks you're going in okay well this is enough
the The Mastermind is a ongoing concept like you
probably need to have you know eight to ten people
yeah and they won't all show up I never got their
first time around it although it was a it was an
ambition to get there and so this time I'm not
going to rush that like I've not been rushing
the roll out of this I've just been going slowly
yeah yeah the first the first business was you
know twenty thousand dollar months real fast yeah
this one is is kind of 10 12K months and so it's
it's a lot slower role I'm not charging Crazy
Prices I'm making it easy for people to work with
me I want to build testimonial strong testimonial
that I can put back into the marketplace to to
increase the value of it yeah so that's what's
going on for me right now so I'm I'm happy to
play it slower this time around just because of
the the experience is just a lot more enjoyable
yeah well and then the Mastermind is at least 25k
if you're talking to c-suite at these companies
and that can be an evolving like you still
do your 12-month coaching at the beginning
when you have enough people you can
do it you can even do some informal
get together for them it doesn't have to be like
I know the vision is three days together but you
could have a day yeah just hey thank you for
being a client let's all go together the vision
doesn't have to be three days yeah that's my other
business I did that yeah that seemed to be what
people wanted to have have two and a half days in
my company was people would come back every day I
was really surprised you know because I I know
it's a big commitment to do that because you've
got to put a lot of things on hold yeah but yeah
it could easily be a day absolutely okay I got
one more idea uh and we need more more we need
more ideas yeah and see where this goes because
I was there was a project that I was a part of a
while ago maybe a decade plus ago called the Judy
project here in Canada and what it did was there
was this woman who I think she was at Royal Bank
which is one of our biggest banks in the country
I think the biggest yeah she was a bit of a client
from World Bank okay so she was an advocate for
women in c-suite getting promoted so she created
uh well she passed and then what she created was
every company from the major companies in Canada
would once a year send their top women who's on a
path who could become c-suite they're not in the
c-suite but they're they're a shining star in
the organization but major companies right and
they would get together once a year at a retreat
and every year company sent a different woman
and I was invited to speak I think it was
the only guy who was it was it was fun uh but
something like that where if there's a cause
that you care about and maybe maybe women's
you know progression isn't like core to your heart
not that you're against it but it may not be at
the core but maybe because of autism maybe someone
with disabilities maybe there's some with a
um inside the organization that connects for
some some reason to you that companies could
send somebody and now you have a once a year
annual program for big corporations and you're
creating these retreats uh and if you know how to
facility you've run through all the same exercises
that you do but you're getting paid by the company
not by the individuals which is a lot easier yeah
and I have I have leads in the business space like
that corporate so large telecommunication company
you'd know who they were yeah that opportunity I'd
love to be able to close one of those even if it
wasn't a retainer if it was just a paid project so
come in talk to the group of individuals it was a
for 40 people and then there's follow-ups and
I can sell privately to those 40 people too so
they could come and Coach with me outside of the
community but the main thrust of that from the my
executive inside was I need you to come and put
my team together and give them common purpose and
give them common Mission and teach them what an
execution excellent standard looks like because I
know that's you and if you come as an independent
they're going to listen to you more than if I re
regurgitate what you already taught me so that
that is yeah very I would be very interested in
that and I it's been in the back of my mind is
opening up those opportunities and for me it's
about the work I'm doing in the background
outside of the room here is re-networking
back into those CEOs who are my friends and
and building the relationship again because
being disconnected because I was doing other
things and they've done other things but they're
still CEOs and they're still running companies and
they've done different things in the tech sector I
know that they need my help it's it's the timing
but I need the relationship in place first yeah
sure selling the businesses is going to be
easier than selling individuals they just they
can justify as a business expense where if it's
yeah there's a personal heart decision yeah and
it's after tax dollars that they're paying you
to coach versus coming in for the team there is
a unique thing though about my market right now
which is a lot of these people have set up llc's
and so they're putting expenses through their
businesses sure and if they don't have it you can
teach them how to do it yeah right which I think
is really a unique thing for me to say yes start
telling people hey you can expense all of this
but still like a Corp a company who has a team
of 100 people or whatever yeah the trick is how
do you do that in an online environment as well
whether they're joining the group with everybody
else because you don't want to be traveling and
flying and yeah now you're back to the business
and I hate going to Seattle or to LA and you know
that that's been the request can you come on site
I said no this can be virtual you don't get all
your people to fly there I would do it virtual but
then no no we're going to fly everybody and you're
going to come okay so I know there's money yeah
because that's just an expense for the company
anyway to get everybody there yeah there were
40 people in this opportunity yeah and it didn't
happen in February but it may happen in May so
whether it's one company that then hires you to
manage their team or or not manage but train and
guide their team I call it motivation yeah but
I don't think there's much training involved
it's because I don't have the time with them
so yes I can go and do an implementation task
with them and I can do some breakouts live in a
workshop type environment but I see it as this is
a motivational experience where I've people walk
away with tools and strategies but I I I think
well if you want me to come in as a retainer and
do training and growth for your people and have
that as part of your development then that could
be the more like the Judy project of Let's help
these people climb the ones the ones that you've
got and especially if there's if there's a cause
that's close to your heart of like who you would
pick what kinds of people on the track up to be
potentially c-suite what's beautiful about that is
it's giant companies paying you so they have
bigger budgets they they want to keep their Stars
and so they're you know that's a nice little bonus
that you're helping them keep their star you know
they're saying like you are the special one you
get to go to James's thing yep uh and it's an
annual program like they come back every year
yeah I mean it's happened to me as when I was
the employee yeah I was you're the star James
you get to go to this group's program and we're
paying them thousands of dollars to take care
of our people so you just you need to pitch it
like you need to pick what is the thing because
it may not have been created before you've set
off some blue lights flashing in my head so
I can go away and look at what's a blue light
flashing just good news yeah just good news it's
not a red light a red light would be this is bad
news blue light is good just the blue light is
is that a British thing I'm just making it up
okay yeah I'm like I need a pen and paper now
blue means go perfect I don't want to miss any
of this stuff but yeah that's right it's I've
got plenty of ideas in my head now about the
competitor market for that and how some of it's
excellent but some of it's missing you know did
me going into the star program keep me no I still
laughed but there's a good reason why so how can I
insert that's that that vital piece of information
the ingredient that says and your people will stay
but the conversation is your you need to be having
in the conversations they need to be having with
you so they stay are important because if you
send them to the the camp and you train them
um you know you're training them to
leave but you have to be aware that
there are other things that need to happen
as well so you can though they will stay
yeah and then if you can narrow down to say I
help like CEOs if you're great at helping CEOs
what are the unique challenges
that Coos face versus
the sales guy or the CEO or whatever yeah right
and if you created this Retreat for potential cos
yeah it's again monotasking or multitasking
depending how you look at it but that's that's
yeah you could create a retreat just it's just
it's picking a cars that you actually care about
yeah that's the most important thing the Judas
project she cared about advancing women in in
the corporate workplace yeah what is the cause of
you care about and then that's what you then go
and pitch to The organizations where like they've
never seen this before because it hasn't existed
before and you're the guy to help make that
happen it's it's similar but it just wouldn't be
you know gender specific it would be you know
taking people who are direct to level now
who want to excel in their career to be in the
c-suite and it's helping them get there that's
the journey I did and it's the journey I know how
how to do that and I can put together a program
curriculum around that that just might be a little
general yeah okay where if it's women then I know
who to Target right so if it's if it's operators
who might be CEO I know who to Target if it's if
it's sales I know who to Target if it's just
anybody who might someday get to the c-suite
it's a little harder to pick who should be the
person who goes so yeah it could be product people
because that's my my background was product people
so it's helping product people get to c-suite
so then if I'm a CEO or CEO or whoever of these
big companies I can like who who's my next product
person who might have a shot at the c-suite
let's send him or her to James's thing okay
and now you're charging 5x what you would charge
like a coaching client because it's going to
Coca-Cola's person and Coca-Cola wants to keep
them and they have insane budgets for training
development especially up their Stars yes okay
so it doesn't have to be the core thing but if
you're good at that and you like it there's a
real opportunity there as well the main thing
for anybody who's building a business like okay so
how do we build a seven figure plus eight figure
coaching business right great so we're starting
with our one-on-ones awesome now we're moving to
a group program and it's really trying to figure
out if you're going to be spending your time on
something heckling like maximized dollars per hour
spent because you've got six hours or whatever a
day to spend so how do we make those hours like
really really really count so then you can hire
team to do everything else so we're trading time
for money at the beginning but at really really
high dollar values and then try to figure out
how to increase our price per hour yeah to then
allow us to afford team to do all of the other
stuff yeah and I'm so I'm in that place so now
of building cash and operating expense account so
I can hire a team yeah I've already got one person
who can help me with web and video activity that
while I love it and would love to do more weapon
video and be the weapon video guy uh it's not
where I'm not going to be able to move as fast
as she is so just kind of have her other side and
doing that work for me is is vital but yeah as I
as I increase the cash then you know it's finding
the right team members to do that including having
a kind of head coach who comes in and works
with some of the people and it's finding that
individual too what I noticed in the in the client
pool is also how they're all instantly hirable
so they the people I have my team could be in my
program already I see that so I'm quite excited
about that that some of them might jump at the
opportunity to come and work in my business and
help me grow it you know whether that would be a
product marketing sales or operational function
they could do it yeah it's pretty cool seeing some
rising stars and you recruit them yourself yeah
yeah there's one in there I hope I would if I had
cash I would say quit your job come and work for
me but I don't have the cash to do that well but
that's the thing right it's like how do you get
the cash building the brand doesn't get you the
cash now it gets you the cash yeah in a couple
years so what's the program like if you focused on
how many people in the 12-month CEO program would
you need to have to hire this person not that many
maybe if I change the pricing so let's say let's
say I move the pricing up 50 I could probably do
three people and that would pay for that person
this person is here is available now you know
in six months maybe they get their dream job
somewhere else and then they're not available
right like that stuff happens but there's always
people yeah unlikely because she's going to
freelance but if I can say situation that's
right he doesn't know that this exists and it's
fine there's other people who will come along
as well too but the num if you only need three
people in your 12-month program versus how many
people in your group coaching at least three or
four times their number right so like which is
easier to go and get versus YouTube revenue or
like on stage work or book deals or something
it just shrinks the time needed to be able
to get the right people on the team to help
you really blow up the business yeah so if you
focus on let me go get three more people into
my 12-month program then I make this higher and
then a million other things open up because you
have that higher help in you yeah and then focus
on getting that yeah and I'm in a good place yeah
I mean this this has been a great week I bought
three more clients in so it's been a good week
so I can shift my attention for the next month
or two because in the next month or two I have
12 to 15 people rolling in different places
in the program and I can focus on finding some
more of my c-suite folks yeah and that would
really help me yeah so that's a that would be
a great thing to be spending the spring on yeah
let's go make some money change the world yeah
I love it thank you James thank you
everyone thanks for your help today let's go
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe see you there